hey guys there's going to be a bit more
of a serious vlog than I've done in the
past because as many of you know and as
many of you probably don't know over
this past weekend there was a series of
tragedies and I won't go into too many
details but they involved shootings and
a lot of death and these are subjects
that I don't normally talk about on my
channel and unfortunately they happen
too often and when they do you guys
often ask me you know to speak out about
it or try to tell you guys a way that we
can prevent it or stop it from happening
and I am very hesitant to do those
things because one I'm not in any way
qualified I do this channel because it's
for entertainment and it's for you guys
and those of you out there who enjoy
watching my videos I know that I make
videos to make you laugh and I know I
make videos to give you guys an escape
from your daily lives and when something
like this something so big that affects
so many people and it kind of crosses
barriers word shouldn't cross barriers I
I just want to say a few things and not
even specifically about the subject at
hand I want to say things to you guys on
an individual level and I know that's
hard because I am literally sitting in
my bathroom talking to a camera that's
going out to over a million people and
it's really hard to make that connection
on an individual level but that's what I
want to do when I make these videos
that's what I really want to do when I
make all my videos and so the one thing
that was standing out my mind that I had
to tell you guys is I want you guys to
be as good as you can be and to be as
connected as you can be to those around
you because we as people we can get
together and we can make you know
protests we can march in the streets we
can do whatever we can make change but
when it comes down to the loneliness
that you feel when you're
by yourself and you are feeling so
isolated from the world and you see
these things that happen and you you
know that you feel like you can't do
anything about it and it's that feeling
of helplessness that really gets people
down and so I just want to tell you as
an individual that the best thing that
you could possibly do is be as good as
you possibly can and be the best person
that you can and try to share that good
with those around you because I'm not
qualified to talk about how to solve
these problems I don't know the first
thing about when preventing these things
from happening but this channel has
always been about encouraging you as an
individual as a creator as a person as a
friend as a member of your community
like whatever you are try to be the best
that you possibly can be so that's all I
want to say about it I don't want to
come across like I'm trying to make
someone else's tragedy about myself
because that's the exact opposite of
what I want and that's never what I
would want to do all I'm trying to say
is that you as an individual you're
never alone and you're never going to be
alone and whether that's good or bad
like literally you're never going to be
alone because what you do and who you
are is always going to affect someone
else in this world like we're literally
all connected and that's obviously a big
kumbaya statement that's all very
happy-go-lucky statement but it's
absolutely true and it's more evident
than ever in these situations so just
remember that the good that you do and
the good that you bring to the world it
really does make a difference
so thank you everybody so much for
watching and as always I'll see you in
the next video bye bye